[SQUEAKING] [RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JOHN GRIMES: OK,
well, I guess I'll
get started, and let
people trickle in,
if anybody else is coming in.
So my name is John Grimes.
And I work in the chemistry
department's Instrumentation
Facility.
And down there,
we've got a number
of different instruments.
We have five mass
spec instruments.
That is not my specialty.
So other than being
able to point them out,
I can't really tell you
that much about them.
I help run NMRs.
And so what I do is I teach
students how to use the NMRs.
I will help them select what
experiments they possibly
need to use in order to give
them the answer that they're
looking for.
And I'll also help them
interpret the data,
or at least get them started
off on interpreting the data so
that they can do
that on their own
when they're doing
their own research.
So what I hope to talk
to you about today
is what an NMR instrument
is and what it actually
consists of as far
as the parts, what
the analytical
technique of NMR is,
and how we measure
the signal, and then
go into some examples of
how to interpret the data.
So here's a picture of one
of our instruments there.
And here's an example
spectrum of adenosine.
So nuclear magnetic resonance
is what NMR stands for.
And it's the study of
molecular structure
by measuring the interaction
of radio frequency energy
with a collection of
nuclei that you've taken
and you've put into a
strong magnetic field.
So it's an analytical technique
that is based on a nucleus's--
or nuclei-- intrinsic
angular momentum.
It is a nondestructive
analytical technique.
And that's important if
you're a graduate student
in the chemistry
department, wherever,
even an undergraduate, and
you have worked long and hard
to synthesize some
natural product that's
15 steps into a
synthesis, you've only
got a half milligram
of that, and it's
a year's worth of
your life's work,
you don't want to destroy
that sample analyzing it.
So you can take
that sample, and you
can put it in a small, little,
cylindrical glass tube.
You can analyze it.
And then you can take
that sample back out
and use it for something else.
So the technique allows you
to determine connectivity
within a molecule.
So I've drawn-- this
is something I'll
bring up a spectrum of later.
It's just three heptanone.
But it will allow you to see
that protons on this terminal
carbon are connected to that
and next to a carbon here
that has two protons on it.
So it looks through
bond connectivity.
And it won't necessarily give
you connectivity all the way
through the molecule, but
you can build up, say,
this chunk of the
molecule and this chunk.
And then you can
link it together--
picture linking together a chain
that allows you to put together
the whole molecule.
It will also show you
interactions through space.
I'm not going to embarrass
myself and try and draw
a protein.
But there can be two
parts of a molecule that
are hundreds of atoms
away from each other
if you were to try and go
through the chemical bonds.
Yet they're held near
each other in space.
And you can monitor
how close they are.
And that helps determine the
three-dimensional structure
of molecules.
And so all the time protein
structures are solved by NMR.
And you can use it to
monitor other processes too,
such as whether a protein
has bound a small molecule,
whether there's hindered
rotation about a bond,
so something like--
where did my chalk go?
If you take something
like dimethylformamide,
this bond here has partial
double bond character.
And you can see separate
peaks for those methyl groups.
And you can rationalize it
by the hindered rotation
around that bond.
And there even other techniques.
And so everybody is going to
be familiar with what NMR is.
And hopefully none of
you have had to have one,
but it's the same physical
technique as an MRI.
So here's an MRI
of, unfortunately,
my daughter's head after
she swam into the pool
end in a swim match.
Nothing happened to her, but
you can take pictures with NMR.
In the past, I've used it
to take pictures of insects.
You can also do
analytical techniques
of in vitro diagnostics.
So there's a test out there
called the NMR LipoProfile.
And it will analyze
your cholesterol, i.e.
the density-- or the
concentration of lipoproteins
that's circulating
around in your blood.
So what is an NMR instrument?
NMR instruments
come in two flavors.
Or at least-- maybe they
come in more flavors,
but, here at MIT, we have
two types of NMR instruments.
There are ones that are
referred to as high-resolution
instruments, which usually
have a stronger magnet,
and they're bigger.
There are also desk--
they're not desktop, but
benchtop instruments,
which is what you're
going to use in your lab.
So each of these has the
exact same constituent parts.
I didn't go over and try and
take your benchtop instrument
apart to get a
picture of those parts
because I wouldn't have
gotten it back together.
And it would have never worked.
So I'm going to go through
one of our instruments
and show you the
individual parts,
but keep in mind it's the
exact same thing that's
in the instrument
that you'll be using.
So you've got to have
a strong magnetic field
to immerse your sample in.
And obviously that's
supplied by a strong magnet.
So magnets will
come in two flavors.
In the benchtop instruments,
they are a permanent magnet.
Has anybody ever taken
apart old computers,
and you can get the
hard drives, and there
are strong magnets in there
that are sort of silver colored?
Those are made from a
neodymium-iron-boron alloy.
And that is what they use for
the permanent magnets that
are in the benchtop systems.
There's been a great improvement
in those in the past, I guess,
15 years or so.
There used not to be any
benchtop instruments.
It was difficult to
engineer and machine
permanent magnets that would
give a uniform magnetic field.
But they've been
able to do that.
And so there are a lot
of benchtop instruments
that are out there now.
The standard NMR-- well, they're
termed high-resolution NMRs
because they have stronger
magnetic fields that then can
be generated from
permanent magnets--
use what are called
superconducting magnets.
So the magnetic
field is generated
by the circulation of electric
charge in a superconductor.
And, if you're familiar with
superconductors, usually,
they have to be below
some specific temperature
in order to maintain
their conductivity.
While the temperature,
the critical temperature,
has come up in recent
years for superconductors,
as far as producing
something that's
easily machinable into wire
that you can wrap into a coil,
the higher temperature--
higher critical temperature
superconductors aren't
easily malleable.
So you still have
to use something
that you've got to
get really cold, i.e.
down to liquid
helium temperature.
So, in a superconducting
magnet, you've got--
think of it as a giant thermos,
which is what this can is.
You've got a hole through
the center, which is called
the room temperature bore.
It's room temperature
because it is not cold.
Your sample, which is
in this little tube
that I showed you
generally, will
be held in what's
called a spinner, so
this little blue thing.
You will put it in
the top of the magnet.
And it will just ride
down on a cushion of air
somewhere to about there
in the center of magnet--
in the center of the magnet.
On the benchtop
instrument, what's nice--
let's see if I can
back up a slide.
All you do-- you can
see it, and it'll
be obvious when you run it
in the lab for yourself.
You just put the tube
right down in there.
You don't have to put it
in any specific holder.
So your sample tube
goes down that bore.
From underneath the
instrument comes
the NMR probe, which I'll
talk about in a second.
So that superconducting
wire is wound
in a coil around that
room temperature bore.
This chamber here, which,
if I could see, is number 6,
that is a chamber that
is full of liquid helium.
So, when you set up one of
these magnets, you cool it off.
You fill that with
liquid helium.
And then you put a charge on
this superconducting wire.
And the charge is
about 100 to 200 amps.
And 200 amps is the
amount of charge
that goes through a
medium-sized house.
So it's got a good amount
of electricity on there
that's circulating around.
As long as you keep it
cold, meaning as long
as you top it off with liquid
helium every few months,
it's going to remain a magnet
and generate a powerful field.
So, if you just had liquid
helium touching metal,
the outside of that metal
would be a big chunk of ice.
So this has an evacuated--
not layer, but I
guess a portion of it
that's evacuated with a high
vacuum to provide insulation.
Outside of that is a
layer of liquid nitrogen.
And we fill that weekly.
And that just cuts down on
any thermal transmission,
even though you've got
a high vacuum there.
And then outside of that is
another high vacuum layer
and then the room.
And so you can walk up to the
can, and you can touch it.
And it won't feel cold at all.
So that's what the
magnet consists of.
The NMR measurement is based
on the strength of the magnet--
so B0 is what I'm calling that--
and the gyromagnetic
ratio of the nuclei
that you're looking at.
And we're going to talk
about hydrogen today.
And so you've got to be able to
synthesize precise frequencies
with precise durations
and power levels
in order to send
those to your sample.
So you've got this console.
It's got amplifiers in there.
100-watt amplifiers is
pretty much the standard.
Actually, I shouldn't even
say that's the standard.
I think ours have 500-watt
amplifiers in there.
You've got different boards.
It used to be that
these all were
plugged in to these long
things with connections.
And it talked through what was
called a backplane, but, now
that these are modern
digital consoles,
it all talks via ethernet.
So everything has an address,
and it talks to each other.
It routes the signal to
where it needs to go.
You've also got some
preamplifiers here.
So all this material
or everything
that's in the console
will generate the signal
that is sent to
your sample in order
to excite it the way
that you need to in order
to get the information
out that you want to.
This also will take the signal
that your sample gives off.
And it will amplify it and
digitize it and send it
to the computer so that
it can be processed
into something you can use.
To send the sample--
well, so the console
generates all that
signal, but it's
got to be broadcast to
your sample somehow.
And so we think of the
probe as the NMR antenna.
So probes can come in a
number of different formats.
There can be probes
for looking at solids.
So you wouldn't even dissolve
your sample in a liquid.
There can be what are
called flow probes where
you've got just--
we call it a cell, but
it's just a container
that's a certain volume.
And you pump your sample up
through a tube into that cell,
analyze it, and then
you pump it out.
There's what we call a
micro coil probe, which
just has a small cell.
So I've used ones or had them
in the past in other labs
where it had a 5
microliter cell.
So you could look at just a
very small amount of things.
There are also probes that
are known as cryogenic probes.
Those, the electronics
that are in the probe
are held at liquid helium or
liquid nitrogen temperature.
And, by doing that, it cuts down
on the inherent electric noise
that's present in the circuits.
And it makes them
more sensitive.
So I've brought a probe
here, and you're not
going to be able to see this
from where you're sitting back
there, but you can come up and
look at it later if you want.
Your benchtop instrument will
have the same stuff in it.
It's just not going to
look like this exactly.
So this is what gets inserted up
from the bottom of the magnet.
And it's just-- it's
screwed in, and it stays
in the bottom of the magnet.
There's only a
couple of connections
where the wires from the
console are hooked up to this.
And so this one, I can
take the cover off of.
And you can look at
this when you come up.
Up in the very top of the probe,
there's a little glass insert.
And there's some
flat ribbons of wire
that are wound around here.
And so I've got
that pointed out.
In fact, I think that's the same
probe that I took a picture of.
And so your sample
will go down, and it
will go right into where
those coils of wire are.
And so the coils of wire
will send the signal
to your sample that's being
generated in the console.
And then, when that
signal gets turned off,
your sample will relax back
to its equilibrium state.
And it will induce
a small voltage
in these coils, which
gets picked up, sent back
through that console
and off to the computer
to generate your spectrum.
So I will leave this right here.
If you come up later to look
at it, feel free to pick it up.
Just be very careful.
This is glass.
And you don't want to bang on
it or bend it because it will--
you can break it, not that
it's working anyways anymore,
but we like to have
it for demonstrations.
OK, so the NMR signal
itself, it's generated
when a collection of
nuclei, meaning your sample,
is placed in a
strong magnetic field
and irradiated with
radio frequency energy
of the appropriate frequency.
And we'll see what
that is in a second.
The signal is a very
small amount of energy
that's given off, as the nuclei
in your sample transition
back to their equilibrium state.
And it's really-- it's a
time-dependent current that's
induced in the coil in the probe
on the order of microvolts.
So it possesses four different--
four properties and only
four properties
that we make use of.
So pictured right here
is an actual NMR signal.
It's what we call a
free induction decay.
It's just a damped sinusoid.
And, out of that, you can
get these four properties
that you can make use of.
The one that we usually make the
most use of is the frequency.
And so I'll tell you
how you can convert this
to this in a few
slides, but where
lines will appear on
this graph tells us
something about the
molecular environment
that whatever gave rise
to that signal is in.
So that's when-- most of the
time, that's what you use.
The next most common piece of
information you use out of it
is the intensity.
So the intensity of a
resonance in the NMR spectrum
is going to be directly
proportional to the number
of nuclei that give
rise to that signal.
And that doesn't
mean just-- well,
it also means just every
nuclei that's in there,
but specifically, for
instance, if you've
got one signal from this group
of protons and one signal
from this group of
protons, their intensity
is going to be equal because
three protons gave rise
to this signal,
and three protons
gave rise to that signal.
So you can use that as an
internal check in molecules
to make sure that you're
identifying peaks correctly.
You can also use it to quantify
molecules, different molecules
that are present in a sample.
And you can even
make a sample where
you've spiked a known
amount of something in there
to serve as a standard
and then quantify
the amount of an unknown
that you've put in there.
Another property is the
phase of this signal.
So what I'm showing
here is not something
you're going to acquire.
It's called a
two-dimensional spectrum,
but what I'm trying to highlight
is that each of these colors,
be it--
I called it red--
I think it might be some
blend of that or blue--
are a different phase.
Specifically, think of this.
Does anybody know what a
two-dimensional map is?
Ever look at a
topographic map where
you've got mountains that
are outlined by contours?
So you can think--
what did I call it?
So I said blue is negative.
So think of the negative--
think of the blue cross peaks
as being holes or going down
into the plane.
And think of the red ones
coming out of the plane.
So the way that this
experiment is acquired,
it makes methylene groups
have a negative phase.
And it makes methyl and methine
groups have a positive phase.
So that's really useful when
you're looking at an unknown
because, right off the
bat, you can just say,
OK, I know that this,
this, this, and this
are from a methyl or methine.
And I know that these blue
peaks are from methylenes.
And then, specifically,
I can look at it
and say, OK, since this one
and this one are in a line
next to each other,
I know that these
are protons on the same carbon.
The last piece of information
that comes out of an NMR signal
is the duration of the decay.
So it can be longer.
It can be shorter.
You can use that like
for things like I hinted
at before where you
have-- small molecules
usually have a long decay.
Large molecules usually
have a very short decay.
So, if you have a protein
that's binding a small molecule
substrate, its decay is going
to transition from something
long to something short.
And you can use that to
tell that your molecule has
been bound.
Any questions?
All right, so unfortunately
not all nuclei
can be measured by NMR.
Any nucleus that
possesses angular momentum
will exhibit a magnetic
moment that will
interact with a magnetic field.
Just like electrons,
if you've learned
about in general chemistry where
you learned the quantum numbers
and you learned about spin,
it's the same for nuclei.
So we say a nucleus possesses
spin in reference to its spin
quantum number,
which is labeled I.
It's easy to think of nuclei
as cute little balls that
are rotating around, but
remember they're not spinning.
It's just an inherent
physical property
that seems like they're
little spinning balls when
they're not.
So there are rules for
determining if a nucleus has
spin or not.
It's present in either half
integer or integer values.
You don't really have to worry
about that for this class.
We're going to be looking at
spin 1/2 nuclei protons, which
are the easiest to interpret.
And luckily protons have a
99.9885% natural abundance.
So it's the most sensitive
and strongest NMR signal
that you can get
out of any nucleus.
There are, like
I said, the rules
for determining whether
something has spin.
Nuclei with even protons--
an even number of protons and
an even number of neutrons
do not have nuclear spin.
And so they're NMR inactive.
Unfortunately, the
next most common thing
that we would love to look at
as organic chemists is carbon.
And carbon has six protons and
six neutrons for carbon-12.
And so we can't.
It's NMR inactive.
Luckily for us,
though, carbon has
an isotope that's 1.1% naturally
abundant, which is C-13.
And we can look at that.
We take a hit on
sensitivity, but we can still
get an NMR spectrum of that.
So that's good.
Some nuclei have multiple
NMR-active isotopes.
That doesn't mean they always
appear in the same spectrum.
They will have different
gyromagnetic ratios.
So they will appear at
different overall frequencies,
but you can look
at-- sometimes, you
can use that to your advantage.
You could take a
spectrum of 10 boron
and a separate
spectrum of 11 boron.
Or a proton, we use the
signal from deuterium
as a lock signal for the magnet
to focus on and counteract
its inherent drift.
So what's the physical
basis of the NMR signal?
In a magnetic field, all
those little magnetic moments
are going to adopt
an orientation
relative to that field.
The allowed orientation
of these moments
is going to be explained
by quantum mechanics.
Luckily, we don't have
to really get into that.
And the process that nuclei
undergo during an experiment
can be rationalized in two ways.
You can think of it
in terms of vectors,
so which way those little
magnetic fields are pointing,
or you can think of it in
terms of the energy levels
that the nuclei
adopt when they're
put in that magnetic field.
So I tried to make a
little cartoon here.
With no magnetic
field, these are
supposed to just be
all randomly oriented,
but, when I immerse my
collection of molecules that's
in my sample in
a magnetic field,
they will line up and
be either with the field
or against the field.
And so, if we look
at one nucleus
when we place it in
a magnetic field,
quantum mechanics tells
us that it's not just
going to point straight up.
There's got to be some
uncertainty in where
that nucleus is pointing.
And so it is going
to precess, meaning
it's going to rotate around, the
direction of the magnetic field
with a characteristic
frequency, which
we call the Larmor frequency.
It's named for--
what's his name?
Joseph Larmor who
was a physicist
back in the late
1800s, early 1900s.
That frequency is
going to be directly
proportional to the
strength of the magnet
that you put your sample in.
I've unfortunately--
so gyromagnetic ratio
can be specified in either
radians per second per tesla
or in hertz per tesla.
I apologize for not being too
careful in that I will jump
back and forth between the two.
And so, for a proton, if we take
a magnet, that's 11.75 tesla
and we put our
sample in there, it's
going to precess around
the field at 500 megahertz.
And so, when we talk
about NMR instruments,
just as far as
what size they are,
they are not specified by
the strength of their magnet.
They're specified
by the frequency
that a proton
precesses in a field
with a magnet of that strength.
So, if you come down to the
DCIF, I'll say I have a 500,
or I have a 600,
or I have a 400.
In the undergraduate teaching
labs, you have a 300.
And I think the benchtop
is a 60 megahertz.
And I'd have to go
look up in a table
or do the calculation
how strong in tesla
a 60 megahertz NMR
magnet is, but that's
the way it's specified.
So that's for one
nuclei when you put it
in the magnetic field,
but our sample is actually
a bunch of different nuclei.
Or not-- well, yes, it's a
bunch of different nuclei.
It's a collection of nuclei.
We don't have to keep track
of every individual nucleus
and deal with the
quantum mechanics
when we look at
an NMR experiment.
We can treat the whole sample
as a collection of the nuclei,
so summing up all the individual
magnetic moments, and just
look at the bulk magnetization.
And so we can use statistical
mechanics in order
to figure out what's going on.
So we put our nucleus--
here's our sample.
We've got, say, 10
milligrams of material.
We've got it dissolved
in about 600 microliters
of a deuterated solvent.
We drop it down so it goes
in our probe in the magnet.
And our collection
of nuclei will
start precessing either
aligned with the field
or aligned opposite the field.
So there will be a slight
energetic preference
for those nuclei to have
their magnetic moment aligned
with the field.
And that population
difference will
result in this net
magnetization that we
call the bulk magnetization.
Let me put that down.
We can jump from
thinking of vectors
to thinking of energy levels.
So everything that is
aligned with the field
is going to be at a
lower energy level.
And we call that just
the plus 1/2 nuclei.
And everything that is
aligned against the field
is going to be at a higher
energy level at negative 1/2.
And so the difference
between these two levels
is going to increase as the
strength of the magnetic field
increases.
And so maybe over here,
on the 60 megahertz,
the difference is
only that much,
but, when you get to our
600, it's a lot more.
Here's where the measurement--
or the principle behind the NMR
measurement comes in.
You're making nuclei transition
from one energy level
to the other energy level.
So you're perturbing their
equilibrium distribution,
and then you're letting
them relax back.
And that's what
gives off the signal
that we make use of in NMR.
So I guess I jumped too
far ahead in my verbiage.
So we have our sample in there.
It's lined up.
And we perturb it
with an RF pulse.
So now I've jump
back to vectors.
If you think of it in terms
of vectors, when you generate
that radio frequency
pulse that has
the frequency equal to the
difference in those energy
levels, you are, in
essence, generating
a small magnetic
field that is aligned.
In this case, it's
arbitrary, but we'll
say it's aligned
along the x-axis.
That acts to topple--
or not topple, tip this bulk
magnetization vector off
of being pointed with the main
field over into the xy-plane.
It's still precessing around at
that characteristic frequency.
And, when it has a
component in the xy-plane,
that will generate a current
in these little coils
in the probe, which is then
received back at the console
and sent to the computer.
So we pulse our sample.
And depending on how long
we turn on that pulse for--
and it's usually the
order of microseconds.
I think our pulses are set up
to be about 10 microseconds.
We can tip this over
to some varying degree.
And so usually we
try and tip it over
by a specific amount, which is
a 90-degree pulse, because that
will generate the maximum amount
of signal that we can get out.
So we tip it over
into the xy-plane.
We turn off that pulse.
And then we let it relax,
and we collect our signal.
Our signal-- I think I said
this before-- is called
the free induction decay.
And so here's another
diagram of it.
We've turned off that pulse.
The signal is
precessing here, but it
relaxes back so that
the component here
gets shorter and shorter
while we grow back
the component in
the z-direction.
That gives us this voltage--
and my laser died--
that gets picked up in the coil.
We can do that multiple times.
So, if you've got
a strong sample,
you can just take
one scan, but usually
we'll take multiple
scans because you
can do what's called
signal averaging, which
is add them together.
And that can help you remove
artifacts, increase your signal
to noise, and other things.
So that's what
the free induction
decay is in the NMR signal.
I put this back in my slide
pack after I gave the slides
to Professor Dolhun to print.
So you don't have this in
your handouts unfortunately.
This is just--
I was thinking this
is still a good way
to show about the NMR signal,
but in terms of the number
of spins and the energy levels.
So here's your equilibrium.
You've got more spins pointing.
I'm saying they're pointing
down in this lower energy level.
You pulse it, and that
equalizes the energy level.
So I forget how
many are in each,
but these are supposed to be
an equal number of arrows.
Then, after you
turn off that pulse,
the spins that got transitioned
to the upper energy level
will relax back down.
So there's a
predominantly-- they're
more predominantly in the lower
energy than the upper energy.
As they do that, they give
off the free induction decay,
which is your NMR signal.
Are these any questions?
OK, so what do we
do with that FID?
Now, I've been doing this--
I don't know-- since 1999.
I can look at an FID.
I can say, well,
that's a long one.
I can look at an
FID and say, yeah,
that's got several different
frequencies in there.
But, as far as looking
at an FID and saying,
oh, that comes from DMF or, oh,
that comes from ethyl acetate,
no, I can't do that.
And I doubt that
anybody else could.
So we have to transform that
and somehow make sense of it.
And so that is done using
a Fourier transform.
And so a Fourier
transform takes something
that is in the time domain.
And it transforms it to
the frequency domain.
And, a long time ago, before
the advent of computers,
NMR wasn't done using Fourier
transforms because it was
computationally too difficult.
And so someone
back in the '60s--
actually, someone famous
at IBM developed a way
to do this to make it
a little bit easier,
but they still had to
print out little cards.
And you'd punch holes in them.
And it would take days and
days to feed it into a machine.
And nowadays your
phone can do it.
It's got more
computational power
than something that
had a whole room.
So everything is done by
Fourier transform now.
That gives us our
spectrum, which
consists of lines,
which we can look at,
and we can interpret
and figure out.
And, no, I couldn't do a
Fourier transform or solve one
in my head or even on paper.
So it's just something
the computer does.
So let's back up.
I've given away a lot of this
because I've already showed
you several spectra, and you see
that there are multiple lines.
But here's the free
curve for the equation
for the frequency
being proportional
to the magnetic field strength.
And you might think,
OK, I have protons.
Why don't I just get one
peak because I have protons?
And I would have
one peak for protons
and one peak for other nuclei.
If it did that, I wouldn't be up
here talking to you about this
because, while it might be
a fine and dandy measurement
for a physicist to use,
it'd be useless for us
in chemistry because
we'd only get
one peak for all the different
protons that are in our sample.
Luckily, when you
put your sample
in a magnet, whatever the
local magnetic environment is
that the nuclei
reside in, that is
going to modify the [INAUDIBLE]
or the external field
that those nuclei feel.
And so that's what spreads
out our single signal
from a proton into the different
regions of the spectrum.
So this is supposed
to be ethyl acetate.
I've got a doubly
bound oxygen here.
I've got a single bound oxygen
here, a methylene, methyl,
and methyl.
So oxygen, I think everybody
might know is electronegative.
It's really greedy.
It doesn't like to
share its electrons.
So it pulls electron
density away
from things that are nearby it.
And that's why I've got
these little deltas up here,
indicating the partial
negative charge.
The things that are
bound closest to it
and even further out, they're
going to be more positively
charged or partial
positively charged
than they would have been
because the electron density is
being pulled away from it.
So that's what helps
spread out those signals.
We call this chemical shift.
It's denoted on a
spectrum as ppm.
And, oftentimes, it's
denoted with delta,
not to be confused
with the delta I've
used for the small charges,
but you might see that
on the axis of it.
So anything that can
perturb electron density
will affect we call it the
shielding of the nucleus,
not only electronegative things,
where nuclei are oriented
in relation to double bonds.
In a benzene ring, you've got
the clouds of electron density
in those pi orbitals.
And things that get
oriented directed into that
will be more shielded.
Things that are sticking off
the ring equatorially-- or not
equatorially, but in the
plane will be deshielded.
So that has an effect.
So all these things
will combine together
to spread out what's
in your spectrum.
So here is just a spectrum
of my ethyl acetate.
And so notice I've
spread it out.
Well, I haven't spread it out.
It is spread out into
three separate signals.
You can use NMR solely as
a fingerprint and tabulate.
I know that only such and such
resonances come at 2 point--
I don't know.
We'll call that 2.01.
And so you can go look in
a table and say, oh, well,
this must be from one of these
small subset of molecules
because they only have
something at 2.01.
It's more important to
be able to rationalize
where things appear by--
or yeah, where things
appear on this spectrum
by where they are
in the molecule
because that will help you
analyze the spectrum better.
So, if we look at this,
we've got three peaks.
Now, I talked about
intensity being
one of the properties
of the signal earlier.
I don't know if
you can see this,
but there's a 3.10 under
there, a 3.10 under here,
and a 2 under here.
So that's the relative
intensity of those signals.
Now, one thing that is common
when you're first learning NMR
is to think that the integrals
are dead on exact so that it
should be 3.00.
No, it's going to be close,
but it's not going to be exact.
You've got to take
great care when you're
acquiring the spectrum to
get your integrals to be
as close to perfect.
So we'd call 3.1 3.
So we know-- we can
look at our molecule.
We've got two methyl groups.
So we can guess that these are
both from the methyl groups
because they integrate the 3 and
that this is from the methylene
because it integrates to 2.
So why is this methylene all
the way down at 4 and these
are up here?
Well, what's the
methylene next to?
It's bound straight
to the oxygen.
So the oxygen is withdrawing
the electron density away
from that methylene.
And it is shifting the peak what
we call downfield, which means
to the left on an NMR spectrum.
That's a leftover term
from in the old days
when they would sweep.
You would actually adjust the
frequency-- or not frequency.
You'd adjust the
strength of the magnet.
So anything that was
down in this direction
used a weaker magnetic
field strength.
Anything that was
up in this direction
used a stronger
magnetic field strength.
Nowadays, we don't do that.
The magnet is always
just what the magnet is,
but those terms
are still around.
So anything to the
left is downfield.
Anything to the
right is upfield.
So this one is
deshielded the most.
It is at 4.1.
The next peak is this one.
Now, we've got to choose.
Is it from this methyl,
or is it from this methyl?
And so you would look, and
you'd say, OK, both of these
are bound to carbon, but the
carbon that this one is bound
to is a carbon that is
doubly bound to an oxygen.
So electron density is being
drawn away from that carbon
by the oxygen. So
that's still going
to also have electron
density being pulled away
from this methyl.
And so that's going
to shift it down here.
This carbon is just
bound to a plain carbon
without a double
bound oxygen on it.
And so it's not
deshielded as much.
Although, if I took
a spectrum that had--
so, if I just had an
alkane like pentane
and I looked at the
terminal methyl on pentane,
it would be over here because
it would not be deshielded
at all compared to this.
Another thing you
might be questioning
is, why are these ones
split into multiple peaks,
but this one is
only a single peak?
Let me make sure I kept
my slides in order.
OK, I did.
That is due to what
is called coupling.
So protons that are
bound to a carbon
will, in essence, talk to
protons on neighboring carbons
through the bonds.
And it's called spin-spin
coupling or scalar coupling.
And so you will have
protons split apart
into characteristic patterns.
What else?
So the splitting on
those peaks is not
dependent on the
main field so that,
if I took that ethyl acetate
spectrum-- and I forget
what strength.
I maybe will say I acquired
that at 500 megahertz.
And I measured the difference
between those peaks.
And we'll say it's 8 hertz.
If I take that
molecule, I put it
in a gigahertz machine,
which is twice as strong,
and I measure the splitting,
it'll still be that same value.
So, for simple spectra, the
splitting follows what's called
the n+1 rule.
And so you look at the number of
protons on neighboring carbons,
and you add that up.
So I guess I should have
drawn another molecule.
Where did my chalk go?
So, for instance, we'll
take this one here.
So CH3, I've got two
protons over here.
So it's going to give
me a simple spectrum.
So it's going to be split
by 2 plus 1 equals 3.
And let's see.
I'm going to close this and
bring up my real spectrum.
So this spectrum
is of 3-heptanone.
And the methyl
here and the methyl
here are these two
resonances over there.
And so you can, in
fact, see that those
are split into three
peaks because each of them
has two protons next to it.
Now, not everything
behaves that way.
When you get into more
complicated molecules,
splitting can be completely
non-rationalizable.
So there are several
ways that can happen.
The most common way is, when the
difference in chemical shifts
between two nuclei is not much
bigger than their coupling
constant, you'll just get a
whole bunch of different peaks.
I can drag up an example
of that in a second.
So let's see.
Oops, OK, so that crashed.
Oh well, so I won't do that.
OK, so I've given
you a table in there
that gives some of
the common splitting
patterns that you will observe.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what do you mean
when you say simple spectrum?
JOHN GRIMES: A simple spectrum
is where the splitting obeys
this n+1 rule.
And so all the multiplets
will be analyzable that way.
And you'll know it.
If you look at
something and you don't
see these common patterns,
you can automatically
say, OK, there's more complex
splitting that's going on in
or non-first-order.
The intensities of those peaks
in a first-order multiplet
will obey or agree
with the coefficients
of a binomial expansion, i.e.
Pascal's triangle.
So, for n equals 2, you will get
1 to 2 to 1 and, for 3, 1 to 3
to 3 to 1.
So they will obey that.
If it was non-first-order,
you might see four peaks,
but you wouldn't have that
same intensity pattern.
So here's some other
examples of NMR spectra.
Here's a simple one, ethanol.
We can look at this, and we
can rationalize where the peaks
appear in the same fashion.
We've got a methyl
group and a methine.
So, if we look at
the methyl group,
we see that there's one, two
protons next to each other.
So we would expect
the resonance for that
to be split into
three separate peaks.
And there, in fact,
we see a triplet.
And then, for the methylene,
not that it's default now
because there's nothing-- or
that's the only other one,
you would expect one,
two, three, four peaks.
And you see that.
And now this is tricky.
Why do you not get
three peaks for the OH,
even though it's got
two protons next to it?
OH and NH have
exchangeable protons.
And so the proton
is coming on and off
that molecule in a faster
time period than the NMR
measurement.
So you just see an average
of the chemical shifts,
meaning it gives
you a single peak,
rather than splitting
into a triplet.
These didn't come out
very big, but it's just
showing you, with bigger
molecules, you get more peaks.
If you zoom in on these,
you'll see that a lot of these
do not give simple triplets
or quartets or doublets,
that you've got a lot of more
complex splitting going on
in the molecule.
And so here's an
example of an ester.
I think that you all are going
to be synthesizing esters.
So, if we look at
these two compounds--
and something I
didn't point out,
well, I'll show you
this in another slide--
anything that appears
in an aromatic ring
is going to be deshielded.
So it's going to
be far downfield.
And I think I said that before.
You've got the electron
density of the pi orbitals
above and below the ring,
which would shield something.
But those protons are held
not there, but straight out
from the ring.
So they're in a
deshielded region.
So, right off the
bat, we can look,
and we can say, OK, we
know that this must be--
or these peaks must be from the
protons on the phenyl rings.
Unfortunately, there's no
integration on here, but you
also, if I had the
integration values,
you would see that those
both integrate to 5.
And that would tell you
something about it too.
So now the question
becomes, which
splitting patterns
in this region
down here agree with
what we see up here?
So, if we look at
our ester, we see
that, on this ester
over here, we've got--
and we saw this ethyl acetate.
We have the methyl and the
methylene bound to the oxygen.
So we know that the
methyl and the methylene
are going to split into
a triplet and a quartet.
And we know that
that quartet is going
to be shifted downfield because
it's bound to that oxygen.
Now, that's not to say
that also, in this one,
they're not going to be split
into a triplet and a quartet.
But this carbonyl
carbon is not going
to drag the peak as far
downfield as it does over here.
So we can say that this
compound here is from this one.
And this peak right here
is my single methylene
that doesn't have any
protons next to it,
whereas this compound over
here is this one here.
Did I just do that?
No, I just said that backwards.
This compound here is this one.
So here's the single
methylene, and here it is.
Here's the methylene that's
split into a quartet.
And it's right there,
whereas, on this one,
this methylene is shifted
a little farther downfield
because now it's
bound to the oxygen.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
OK.
I'm not going to go
over this completely.
You can look at this.
You can also look up--
you can find stuff
like this online everywhere.
This is a fellow
over in England who
puts out these graphics
called Compound Chem.
I don't know if anybody
follows him on Twitter,
but he's got all sorts of great
chemistry education graphics.
This is one that just
gives you an idea
of the different chemical shift
values and where things appear.
And so you can see an
OH on a carboxylic acid
is going to be very deshielded.
Amide protons are going to be
in this region and et cetera.
So that I can give
you some idea of where
to look for resonances.
I said that we can
take spectra of carbon.
Carbon is a lot less
sensitive than proton.
In fact, sensitivity-wise,
if you just
compare the gyromagnetic
ratio of carbon to proton,
it's a fourth of proton.
So, like I said, we
specify our magnets
by the precession
frequency of protons.
So, on a 500-megahertz
instrument,
it would be a 125-megahertz
carbon instrument.
So you take that one
fourth of a hit because
of the gyromagnetic
ratio, but then
you also take a big
hit because only 1.1%
of the carbon present
in your sample
is made of carbon-13, which
is the NMR-active carbon.
The rest of it is carbon-12,
which is NMR inactive.
But you can still
acquire carbon spectrum.
A carbon spectra has a much
bigger frequency spread.
So you don't have
overlap as much.
That can be very useful.
And this combined with
a proton can tell you
a lot about your molecule.
You're not going to acquire
these on the benchtop
instrument.
Although, I guess
it probably will
if you have a very, very
concentrated sample.
This is just to show an example.
You can do very complex
samples or experiments.
So this is a three-dimensional
spectrum of a protein.
So this is something you would
use in determining a protein
structure.
I've never acquired
one of these.
So all I can tell
you is that you're
looking both at carbon
resonance-- what
do we have up here?
Oh OK, sorry.
So it's the protein
was expressed
by bacteria that were growing in
food that was labeled with N-15
and C-13 so that
there's incorporation
of those nuclei in there.
And it will give you a
signal, and you can use that.
Let's see.
I'm almost finished, but I
think we're about out of time.
Sample preparation, when
you're preparing your samples,
it is important to
prepare clean samples.
There should not be particulate
matter in your samples.
You should filter them if you
do have particulate matter
from your reaction
because that will--
having particles in there will
lead to poorer spectra that
will be difficult to interpret.
NMR are the very thin,
glass-walled tubes.
So be careful with them.
If you snap this, you can
easily stick it in your hand.
So be very careful with that.
Use a deuterated solvent when
you're preparing your samples.
I think you will be given
that by your TAs anyways.
And never put a dirty
tube in the instrument.
You should always clean the
tube off on the outside.
And then I think the last slide
that I have is about shimming.
Shimming is adjusting
the homogeneity
of the magnetic field.
So, if you remember
from that equation--
and you don't even have to
know how to solve this--
so your frequency is
directly proportional
to the magnetic field strength.
Shimming means making your
magnetic field homogeneous
so that the top of your sample
feels the same strength field
as the bottom of your sample.
The machine will do
it automatically,
but, if the top of
your sample feels
a different magnetic field
strength than the bottom,
then it's going to have two
separate frequencies for where
those protons precess, which
means the line broadens out.
And, if that line
broadens out, it
makes it harder to interpret.
And then I'll skip
over this one.
The last thing, I
guess, questions, I
put in some references in here.
This is a great thing
to do with old magnets.
If you're artistic
with cutting tools,
I would love to have my own
pizza oven with an old magnet.
So, if anybody has any
questions, please let me know.
AUDIENCE: Pretty cool lesson.
JOHN GRIMES: And no, that's
not a friend of mine's either.
I just snagged that off the web.
AUDIENCE: That's hilarious.
JOHN GRIMES: Anything else?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And, if you want to look
at this if you have time,
you can come up.